-"F9" -- gosh,
we're so excited about this.
And I can't think of
a better movie
to bring back theaters, safely.
If it's safe -- it is -- go to a
movie theater and watch "F9."
It is loud. It is fast.
Well, it's furious.
It is loud, but it is an
action-packed movie.
It's got a great story.
Now, this is -- You've taken it
to another level.
Did you even think
you'd end up going this far?
-You know,
if you would have told me
we would be here
20 years from now...
-Yeah.
-...20 years ago, I would have
thought you were crazy.
-Yeah. But now you're -- I mean,
let me just put this
in perspective for you.
Actually, in this movie,
we talk about your family.
-Mm-hmm.
-But in real life, your son is
in the movie, playing you.
-Oh!
-That couldn't have happened.
That's amazing.
[ Laughs ]
But that couldn't have happened.
That's great.
How was that?
-Can you believe that?
Alright, so, first of all,
it wasn't my idea.
I can't take the credit.
It was Justin Lin, the director.
-The director, yeah.
-But we've been making these
movies for so long
that every time one of
my children were born,
I was usually working on
a "Fast and Furious" movie.
So, the director and the cast
all have their own relationship
with my children.
And it was his idea
for my son to play Young Dom.
And the irony is,
the thing I remember the most
was coming home that day,
because when you see the movie,
it's kind of a deep scene,
so Dom is in
a deep state of mind.
And my son was watching me
work the whole day,
and it wasn't till I got home,
when I saw a twinkle in his eye
because he had finally
seen his father come home,
as opposed to being with
Dom Toretto the whole day.
It was so adorable.
It was so beautiful.
-Wow! It's a big deal.
That's what makes -- I mean,
obviously, fans of the movie --
we kind of grew -- Everyone grew
with you and these characters.
-And I grew with you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No. Sit down!
You have to sit down!
Vin, you can't go in the
audience! Come on!
-I grew with you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm here for you!
We make the movie for you!
-Let's go do -- Here, we can
throw the clip
from on the stairs.
-Let's do the clip.
-Come here, come on, come on.
-Come on. Let's do it.
-Let's go throw the clip
from over here.
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
-I want to show -- I want to
show everyone a clip.
Here is Vin Diesel in "F9."
Take a look at this.
-Where's the bridge?
No. No, no.
Dom...
Well, that was new.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Vin Diesel, everybody!
That's how you do it
right there.
"F9" hits theaters this Friday.